Let's get started.
One announcement. And that is the
reminder about the upcoming
celebration Wednesday.
There is the coverage.
It is up here on the screen.
It starts midpoint Lecture 17
starting with Bragg's Law and goes
through to the end of November 8th,
Lecture 24, Diffusion. And that
will be the coverage.
Let's get on with today's lesson.
It is a continuation of what we
began talking about on Wednesday.
We started looking at solution
chemistry, and we recognized that
bonding was the key to understanding
why thing mix,
why things don't mix.
And, along the way, we came up with
some metrics, including the
solubility product which was
superior to simply saturation
solubility because it allowed us to
look at what happens when there is a
plurality of solutes.
And we came to know the common ion
effect which in the presence of a
common ion we observed repressed
solubility. Today I want to talk
about a subset,
some specialized solution chemistry.
And that takes us to acids and
bases, which are pervasive.
Perhaps you got up this morning and
washed your hair with pH balanced
shampoo and treated yourself to some
orange juice with citric
and ascorbic acid.
Maybe you had the radio playing
powered by zinc-alkaline batteries.
I started my car thanks to a lead
acid battery. And I had some
appliances running,
electricity-generated coal fired
plant which was spewing sulfur
dioxide generating acid rain.
We are off to a good start. Acids
and bases are everywhere.
What I wanted to do today was to go
a little bit deeper into acids and
bases. And, unlike last day,
today we will have some history.
We are going to go back in time.
And we are going to go way, way
back because acids and bases have
been known into antiquity.
In fact, humans have used acids in
materials processing and in the
processing of food.
The whole notion of pickling
involves denaturing of protein by a
shift in acidity.
Acid comes from the Latin word.
Acid derives from the Latin word
acidus. And acidus means sour or
tart. And that indeed is the taste
of acid to us.
And then modern chemistry,
we go to just the predawn of the
French Revolution to France
and Lavoisier.
And it was Lavoisier in 1779,
you know, I am going to be talking
about a number of people from
different countries.
A lot of them are from Europe,
so what I thought I would do, to
keep everybody straight,
I would use the oval sticker you see
on the back of a car.
Lavoisier would have an F from
France. He would be driving a
Peugeot or Renault undoubtedly.
And Lavoisier tried to understand
acids and bases,
and he reasoned that oxygen was the
key, that oxygen is present in acids.
And we know this to be wrong now,
but he spent much of his career
studying combustion.
In fact, there was an intense
rivalry between Lavoisier in France,
Joseph Priestley in Great Britain
and Scheele in Sweden to try to
understand combustion.
What was it about air that sustains
combustion?
And they eventually figured out that
it was a constituent of air which
they named oxygen.
And it is named oxy.
This comes from the Greek which
means sharp as in tart.
Oddly enough, and of course the gen
particle, you understand,
is meaning to be born, or as we say
to generate and so on.
Oddly enough, the name oxygen is a
complete irony.
Because it is named by someone who
thought it was a constituent of all
acids. And it is not,
but the name remains. That is the
way things were in 1779.
And then Lavoisier subsequently
perished in the French Revolution.
Then we go to Britain and Sir
Humphrey Davy in 1810.
He would have a GB, driving
probably a Jaguar or maybe
an Aston-Martin.
And he reasoned that it was hydrogen
present in all acids.
And that was a good insight,
and that is where it stayed. He
didn't talk about anything beyond
that. He didn't say what the form
of hydrogen was.
He simply said that it was present
in all acids. Then the next
milestone comes in 1887.
None other than Arrhenius.
Arrhenius in 1887.
And he was in Sweden so he has a S.
He is probably driving a Volvo.
What he did is said not only is
hydrogen present in all acids,
but the acid dissociates in water in
order to donate protons.
Acid is a substance that
dissociates in water giving
the proton, H plus.
And he further talked about the
compliment of the acid which he
called the base.
And he defined the base as a
substance that dissociates in water
to give the OH minus, the hydroxyl.
We have hydroxyl ion and proton.
This is what Arrhenius told us.
This was all part and parcel of his
major contribution that won him the
Nobel Prize, which was the theory of
electrolytic dissociation.
And this was really important
because it set the stage for
electrochemical processing.
What he reasoned is that when you
inject charged species into water,
you do the same as we do when we
dope a semiconductor and we raise
the conductivity.
We saw evidence for that last day.
Let's look at two examples. This
is HCl as a gas.
Hydrogen chloride as a gas.
This is a polar molecule. You have
done the analysis of
this many times.
If we bubble this through water,
it will dissolve. And, according to
Arrhenius, dissociate to give us the
proton which is now dissolved in
water denoted aq for aqueous and
chloride ion. We can see injection
of charges, pluses and minuses.
And sodium hydroxide as a
prototypical example of a base.
It is a solid at room temperature.
And, if it dissolves in water, it
gives us sodium ion plus hydroxyl.
Furthermore, Arrhenius said that
there is an overarching reaction
that involves reconstitution of the
solvent. Water,
in this case, is acting as the
solvent. We can run the reaction
vertically now.
We can take HCl aqueous plus NaOH
aqueous to give us NaCl
aqueous plus H2O.
What we are doing is reacting the
acid with the base to get the
solvent back - water - plus salt.
And this is the neutralization
reaction. That is to take us away
from either acidic or basic solution.
Neutralization involves
recombination of the solvent.
Everything I am going to talk about
today is in reference to aqueous
solution chemistry, acids and bases.
But these definitions of proton
donor and so on apply to nonaqueous
solvents. But for 3.
91 we are going to stay in the
aqueous phase.
Now, what are the shortcomings of
Arrhenius' theory?
It was good for the late 1880s,
but shortcomings always manifest
themselves through data.
And people had known for quite some
time that they could dissolve
ammonia, another molecule that we
have seen in 3.091.
They could dissolve ammonia in water.
And when they dissolved ammonia in
water they found they got an aqueous
solution that neutralizes acid.
Then they concluded that ammonia
dissolved in water is acting as
though it is a base,
but there is no hydroxyl here.
There is no oxygen so you cannot
make OH minus here.
Something was incomplete.
How to explain in the absence of OH
minus? Well, you had to wait until
the 20th century.
And the explanation came from two
places simultaneously. Bronsted,
1923 in Denmark.
I suppose he is driving a Volvo,
too. And Lowry in the UK. Bronsted
and Lowry both independently in the
same year enunciated an enhanced
definition, a broader definition of
acid and base which is as follows.
Acid remains the same as Arrhenius.
It is a substance that is a proton
donor. That is the
same as Arrhenius.
But then, to capture the notion that
an aqueous solution of ammonia can
act as a base,
they define the base in terms of
something that is chemistry-free.
And they said this is something
that is a proton acceptor.
Now, that is different. No mention
of hydroxyl. Anything that accepts
proton would fall under the
definition of Bronsted-Lowry base.
Here is the prototypical reaction.
Any substance that has a proton, I
am going to write proton plus
everything else,
so A represents the rest of the
chemistry of the compound where H is
a hydrogen that can be dissolved in
water and liberated.
This is a proton donor.
And for the rest of the lecture,
instead of writing H plus, I am
going to write "p+"
to indicate proton.
HA is a proton donor,
and it reacts with some
Bronsted-Lowry base,
which is a proton acceptor.
And when it reacts, B accepts the
proton and becomes BH plus.
And HA has lost a proton, and it is
now simply A minus.
If you walked in the room,
and I know this never happens,
but if you had momentarily dozed off
and hadn't caught the last thing
that I said, you might look at the
right-hand side of the equation and
say, well, BH plus has a proton that
it can give away and become naked B.
This BH plus is also a proton donor
and A minus, we know from looking at
the left side of the equation,
is perfectly capable of bonding to H.
This A minus must be also a proton
acceptor. Now what do we see?
We see that the equation comes in
conjunction. That B and BH plus are
donor and acceptor,
and they are associated with one
another so I am going to denote that,
that B and BH plus are associated
with one another and HA and A minus
are associated with one another.
And we call such pairs conjugate
pairs. These are conjugate pairs.
Con is the Latin for with and
jugara is the Latin for to marry and
is also the same word for yoke.
I think if you pronounce the j as a
y, you can see how you get yoke in
modern English.
And, in fact, I will designate
these with yoke to show that they
are conjugate acid-base pairs.
And just to be clear about
definitions, let's look.
HA, this is a proton donor,
so this is both a Bronsted-Lowry
acid and it is also an Arrhenius
acid. It conforms to the old
definition of Arrhenius.
Now, this is a proton acceptor B.
Therefore, it is a Bronsted-Lowry
base. But it is not an Arrhenius
base because it has no hydroxyl.
You can see this is a case of in
some cases there is an overlap and
others there is not.
These are both Bronsted-Lowry.
This is Bronsted-Lowry acid. This
would be an Arrhenius acid because
it has a proton.
It can give away a proton.
This is both a Bronsted-Lowry acid
and an Arrhenius acid.
And this one here, of course,
is simply a Bronsted-Lowry base.
It is not an Arrhenius base because
it has no proton.
You can see there is a nice
contrast between the two.
That means, in the light of Bronsted
and Lowry, we view acid-base
reactions are,
in fact, proton transfer reactions.
Follow the proton - that is the
message here. Follow the proton.
In fact, the proton is the bearer
of acidity. Follow the bouncing
ball. Follow the bouncing proton,
which is the bearer of acidity.
Where the proton goes that is where
the acid is. Now let's go back to
ammonia and see if we have solved
the problem. Now I will write the
ammonia reaction.
NH3, which is now dissolved in
water, is now aqueous,
plus water, H2O. What ammonia can
do is neutralize water.
What it does is neutralizes water,
not by donating hydroxyls but by
drawing up, taking out of
circulation protons.
Because acid and base is really a
ratio. Acid has an excess of
protons. If I want to get rid of
the acid, I can either flood it with
base or somehow get a vacuum in
there and draw up all the protons.
That is what ammonia is doing. And
leaving behind hydroxyl.
It is generating hydroxyl
indirectly.
And so let's call these what they
are. This is a proton acceptor.
And here is its conjugate acid.
This is obviously a proton donor.
And, if we come up with a new,
improved theory and we do not
declare hydroxyl a base,
we failed. We better make sure that
is the case. And this indeed is a
proton acceptor. And leaving water.
Water is acting as a proton donor.
Pure water acting opposite ammonia
is acting as an acid here.
This is Bronsted-Lowry base.
We solved the thorny problem of the
observation that ammonia has the
capacity to neutralize some
solutions, and this water is acting
as a Bronsted-Lowry acid.
And then you see the conjugate acid
and base pairs as follows.
Here water and hydroxyl are
conjugates, and ammonia and this ion
here which is called ammonium.
Ammonium is one of the few
polyatomic ions that is positive.
Most of the polyatomic ions, things
like carbonate,
sulfate and phosphate are negative.
But this is one of the few that is
positive. I think we should have
special respect for ammonium,
for its rarity. It is a rara avis.
It is a rare bird.
Now let's go into the chemistry.
How do we identify substances that
are going to act as Bronsted-Lowry
bases? Whenever I ask you how,
that is your queen of diamonds.
What do you do?
He said how, I go let's look at
electronic structure.
I am going to look at electronic
structure of ammonia and of proton,
because ammonia is a proton acceptor.
Let's look at it.
Here is proton.
Actually, I said I was going to
write it only as P plus,
but I am going to do it this one
last time. What is the Lewis
structure of this?
Where are the electrons?
There are none. This brings
nothing. This is proton,
and proton contributes nothing when
it enters into bonds.
It is like a needy friend.
It just takes. It does not give.
It takes your time, drains your
emotional energy.
That is proton.
We all have protons in our lives,
I am sure. And I am not just
talking about the orange juice.
Now let's look at ammonia. Ammonia
is NH3. Nitrogen has five valence
electrons. Three of them are shared
with the three hydrogens.
And there are two valence electrons
sitting up here in their own orbital.
And, in the past,
we were circling these in blue and
calling them nonbonding electrons.
This is a nonbonding pair.
Well, guess what happens? You have
a situation where the proton has no
electrons, and it wants to glom onto
something that will be the base
because it is a proton acceptor.
The only thing that can accept
protons must come up with both
electrons. It is axiomatic.
The only substances that could
possibly act as Bronsted-Lowry bases
must be substances endowed with lone
pairs or nonbonding electrons.
To find Bronsted-Lowry bases look
for nonbonding pairs.
All you need is one. Let's look at
some other substances that could do
this. How about water?
What about water? Well,
we could do the Lewis structure of
water, H-O-H.
Oxygen has six valence electrons.
Two are in the orbitals sharing
with hydrogen leaving us with not
one but two nonbonding pairs.
We know that this tells us that
water could possibly act as a
Bronsted-Lowry base.
And what is the conjugate acid?
If this is not Bronsted-Lowry base,
it allows a proton to attach here.
That means we are going to have
three hydrogens here.
And the conjugate base is shown as
follows. It is going to be H-H-H.
And then the last nonbonding pair.
And this has the chemical formula
of H3O plus and has the name
hydronium. Hydronium is the
conjugate acid to water which is
acting as a Bronsted-Lowry base.
We can write the reaction and show
that water is very versatile.
I am going to take water and react
it with water.
Water plus water,
if I wanted to just waste your time,
I would write 2H2O on the right-hand
side and leave the auditorium,
but I decided I want to keep my job.
And so what I am going to do
instead is write H3O plus to give
you the conjugate acid leaving
behind OH minus as the
conjugate base.
This is acid here and this is base.
I am looking at the two waters. I
am just designating them arbitrarily.
Let's make this acid.
And, of course, hydroxyl must be a
base. And then we can group them in
conjugate pairs.
H2O is a conjugate to hydronium and
H2O is a conjugate to hydroxyl.
We have the two conjugate pairs
here. And we say that such
substances that can be both proton
donors and proton acceptors have
this dual nature associated
with them.
And we call these amphiprotic.
They behave in two ways with
respect to proton.
It is sort of like amphitheater.
If you are looking top down, a
Roman theater looks like this.
Here is the stage and here are all
the terraces, the screaming people
and everything else.
What you can do is take two theaters
and put them together.
Now you have theater in the round.
That is an amphitheater. This is
amphiprotic because now you can look
at the stage from both sides and
scream. It turns out that both
hydronium and hydroxyl are very
strong. They have a very high
chemical potential.
That means it does not take much of
them to express themselves.
Both have high chemical potential.
And this chemical potential is
analogous to gravitational potential.
The higher the chemical potential
the greater the chemical reactivity,
the greater the chemical power.
They have a very high chemical
potential, certainly much greater
than that of pure water.
Pure water is relatively stable and
calm, and so it takes very little
for them to express themselves.
And it turns out that the extent of
that reaction that I have written is
really very minimal.
And at 25 degrees C you expect that
reaction to give about one part in
ten million. The degree of
dissociation of water is about ten
to the minus seven.
And, obviously from the
stoichiometry,
whenever water dissociates you get
equal numbers of hydronium and
hydroxyl. And this reaction in
which water decomposes,
dissociates is called the
self-dissociation reaction.
Or some people also refer to it as
self-ionization.
We start with neutral water,
it dissociates and we get the
hydronium and the hydroxyl.
And we know that pure water is a
very poor conductor.
In fact, it is an insulator.
We saw that last day.
And this is proof of it.
Even though we have carriers here,
these are both charge carriers, we
have so few of them that it does not
do much to give us electrical
conductivity. Analogous to a
solubility product,
we can write a constant called Kw,
which is analogous to a solubility
product. And it is the water
dissociation product.
And it is simply the product of the
concentration of hydronium ion and
the concentration of hydroxyl ion.
And why are we doing this?
Because we saw last day that if we
express solubility by a single
number that would only work in
one-solute solutions.
If we use the solubility product,
we could answer questions what
happens when there is a second
solute coming in with a common ion.
The same thing here. If all you
have is pure water,
I could just tell you that the
dissociation constant is ten to the
minus seven, end of story.
But if I use this product and then
throw in a second source of acid,
this product will remain the same,
but the hydroxyl will move up and
down. This is setting the stage for
acid-base equilibria.
And, before I draw the double line,
let me point out that this is a
vanishingly small number.
It is the square of ten to the
minus seven. It is ten to the minus
fourteen at room temperature.
These are pitifully small numbers.
We can see that if we add another
source of acid then the proton level
will go down and we end up with
something that is acidic or vice
versa. We can then define an acidic
solution as one that is out of
equilibrium with it.
This is a neutral solution.
I started with pure water. It is
self-dissociated.
An acidic solution has another
source of proton.
In that case, the concentration of
hydronium ion exceeds the
concentration of hydroxyl ion
because of another source.
This is not from self-dissociation.
Not self-dissociation. Not
self-ionization.
We have some other source.
And the alternative is the basic
solution. And,
in that case, the concentration of
hydronium is less than the
concentration of hydroxyl.
Again, not in self-dissociation.
We have to have some other donor
here.
The acidic solution is proton-rich.
Whereas, the basic solution is
proton deficient.
How do we maintain charge
neutrality? Well,
we can put in some other negative.
We can put in some anion. We can
maintain charge neutrality in other
ways. By the way,
sometimes we call this alkaline
solutions, basic.
We do not call it the zinc basic
battery. We call it the
zinc alkaline battery.
And that comes from Arabic al qaly
which goes back to about the 10th
century where there was a
recognition that if you took the
calcined ashes of certain plants and
dissolved them in water they made
this tart solution that we now know
to be the same as an alkaline
solution giving us the higher.
We can also call it alkaline. That
is the same thing.
Now what we can do is look at how
this varies.
I draw your attention to the trace
here. This is simply the plot of
this equilibrium.
All I am doing is plotting the Kw
at 25 degrees C.
And what you see is that exactly
when we have a neutral solution,
the concentration of proton equals
the concentration of hydroxyl.
They are both at ten to the minus
seven. If we end up with something
that has an excess of proton then
necessarily if the product is
constant, if proton number goes up
hydroxyl number goes down,
and vice versa.
This is how this system operates.
And I don't like this one because
it is nonlinear,
and I really don't like nonlinearity
because we basically have this.
I cannot do anything but eyeball it.
It is xy equals constant.
It is a rectangular hyperbola.
No good. What I would like to do
is use some kind of transformation
and convert this into
a straight line.
I would like to have some kind of f
of x and a g of y.
And, doing so, I would end up with
something that is a straight line.
And that offers me two advantages.
First of all, I can take a look at
some data set and look at,
with the naked eye, goodness of fit
to see if my system is behaving,
if my data are good. And the second
thing is if I understand how to
construct the transformation,
this may give me clues as to the
underlying science.
That is why we try to get away from
these nonlinear representations and
do something that is linear.
And for that we go to Denmark,
1909, a young biochemist by the name
of Sorensen. In keeping with our
tradition today he gets the Denmark
sticker. He was a biochemist
working at the Carlsberg
Brewery in Copenhagen.
Carlsberg Brewery had a research
biochemist working.
Why? When you are brewing beer,
you want to control the acidity of
the mash in order to make sure that
your brewing is on chemical target.
What he did, being a good chemist,
was looked at the situation and said
I do not like this nonlinearity.
He said I am going to, if you will
pardon the pun, straighten
things out.
And so what he did was say I am
going to define a quantity that will
represent the chemical potential of
hydrogen, the chemical potential of
let's say hydronium.
He used the symbol lowercase p and
the uppercase H for the chemical
potential of hydronium.
And he defined this in a logarithmic
fashion. It is log base ten of the
hydronium concentration.
Furthermore, being practical,
he recognized that these are always
numbers less than one.
The log of a number less than one
is a negative number.
Who wants to drag negative numbers
around? He defined it with a minus
sign in front of it so that a ten to
the minus seven concentration
becomes a pH plus seven.
And he furthermore defined a
chemical potential of hydronium ion,
pOH as minus log base ten of the
concentration of hydroxyl.
If you take this and put this to
the plot you will see the following.
You end up now with a straight line.
We have accomplished our mission of
getting something that allows us
easily to determine goodness of fit.
And the second thing is look at the
range. We move here from ten to the
fourteen down to one.
Whereas, on this plot,
we started at ten to the minus seven
and move barely a decade.
By linearizing on a log-log plot,
we have a much, much greater range
of chemistry to express.
And so now we talk about acid,
which is something that has low pH
because the pH is defined as minus
the log of the hydrogen
ion concentration.
Proton rich is low pH and the base
is something that is high pH,
according to this definition. And
now we have, instead of that xy
equals constant,
we have x plus y equals constant.
And this is now very, very nice to
master, where this is the pH and the
ordinate is the pOH.
Let's look at some values,
put some values on it. Here are
some common substances.
We have here water in the center,
milk, blood. These are very nearly
neutral, mildly acidic and mildly
alkaline. If you drank coffee this
morning, you drank something that
was more acidic.
Tomato is more acidic.
I know you don't know anything
about this, but you have probably
read in the newspapers or in
magazines people describing wines as
being mildly acidic and so on.
And indeed the pH is down here.
If the wine spoils it becomes sour
wine, vin aigre.
Aigre, it means eager,
but the Medieval meaning of eager
was something that was rather fresh,
rather impetuous, tart. This is
vinegar. Colas are down here thanks
to benzoic and phosphoric acid.
Lemon juice is here. If you drink
a lot of Coke or Pepsi,
you are coming in at about pH 3,
but your stomach is down around pH 1.
.
Some of us just cannot take a lot of
acidic media because they just drive
our pH even lower because we keep
contributing more and more protons.
And, if our stomach wall is not up
to it, it will get ulcerated.
What do we do? We shift the pH
back. How do we shift the pH back?
We introduce something that is a
proton acceptor,
a vacuum cleaner for the protons.
And so the classical formula is
something in the liquid form.
It is the suspension Milk of
Magnesia or in the tablet form
things like Rolaids,
Tums and so on. All they are doing
is contributing proton acceptors and
driving the pH in the positive
direction. I suppose if you were
really aggressive you could try
household ammonia,
but I would counsel against it.
Be patient. I counsel against
doing that. And this gives you some
sense of scale. Now we
know what we have.
So far we have been assuming if I
introduce an acid it dissociates and
I get protons.
All acids are not created equal.
Some are strong and some are weak.
And what do we mean by that? Let's
first of all look at the strong acid.
If I have a solution of one molar
HCl, hydrochloric acid,
I can assume that this dissociates
fully to give me one molar hydronium.
The concentration of
hydronium is exactly.
I get total dissociation.
But that is not always the case.
We can look at something that is a
little bit weaker.
I am going to look at acetic acid.
This is the constituent of vinegar.
Its formula is given as follows,
CH3COOH. This frontal part is
acetate and then plus proton.
I want to break this into two steps.
First of all we have, if you like,
an acetate, hydrogen acetate.
And then what we will do is
dissolve it in water to get CH3COOH.
And I am just going to write aq.
All I have done is dissolved the
compound in water.
And now what I want to do is look at
its extent of dissociation.
Let's just call this dissolution.
All things that dissolve do not
necessarily dissociate fully.
Let's look at its now dissociation
reaction. For that we write CH3COOH
which is now in solution plus water.
And water is going to contribute in
the following.
We have H3O plus.
It makes the hydronium ion and then
leaves behind the acetate ion.
Now, compare. In one molar HCl,
we have one molar hydronium. In one
molar acetic acid,
we have only about a half a percent.
0.4% reacts to give H3O plus and the
acetate ion. If we write then an
acid dissociation constant,
it is going to be the product of
hydronium and acetate over water,
we will end up with hydronium times
acetate divided by the
undissociated acid.
And, in this case,
the number is ten to the minus five.
There is very little dissociation.
Ten to the minus five is down around
ten to the minus seven which was
self-ionization of water.
This is a very weak acid.
This is a very weak poor proton
donor. It is a poor proton donor.
What am I showing?
I am showing that it dissolves but
it does not dissociate.
What we need, in order to have full
acidity, is to have not only the
substance dissolve but it has to
dissociate to give us protons.
This we call a weak acid. And we
see we have a very low value of the
Ka which is termed the acid
dissociation constant.
And it is analogous to the
solubility product that
we met last day.
Acid dissociation constant for HCl,
just for reference, Ka for HCl is
equal to the proton concentration
times the chloride ion concentration
over the dissolved but undissociated
HCl. There is almost none of this.
All the HCl virtually dissociates.
And this number is ten to the plus
six. There is a ratio of ten to the
eleventh. Look at this.
This is ten to the minus five.
This is ten to the plus six. It is
ratio of ten to the eleven.
In six molar HCl we have 99.
6% dissociation, conversion to H3O
plus. We call this a very,
very strong acid, and this is a weak
acid. Strong acids,
Ka is greater than one.
And in weak acids, Ka is less than
one.
And then you have these moderate
acids right around the middle.
And I have some charts here to
illustrate this.
This is a very primitive graphic to
show that in the case of a strong
acid, you get 100% dissociation.
All of the H becomes H3O plus. In
a weak acid, you only get partial
dissociation. You still have a lot
of this undissociated neutral stuff,
which is not active. There is no
proton. There is no acidity.
And then a very weak acid
essentially does not dissociate.
It goes in a solution and you have a
molecular liquid.
There are no protons.
And so no protons, this is a poor
conductor of electricity.
Conductivity will allow you to
track the amount of dissociation.
This is taken from your reading.
This is Table 11.
. You can see the acid dissociation
constants. There is HCl at ten to
the plus six. HBr.
HI. There is HF. Hydrofluoric
acid is actually a mildly weak acid.
And then down here you have citric
and so on. There is carbonic which
is the seltzer and so on.
This is an interesting one.
Why hydroiodic acid is even
stronger than hydrochloric acid is
because you have here a stronger
bond strength.
Fluorine is smaller,
it pulls proton in tighter,
and so the degree of dissociation is
not as great as it is here.
These end up scaling as the acid
dissociation constants.
In general, equal acid strength does
not mean equal concentration.
Now let's go to the last definition.
Also 1923, but we are going
stateside now.
We are going to the United States.
1923, G.N. Lewis, the same person
that gave us the Lewis Structure
Notation. We will put USA on the
back of his undoubtedly Chevrolet.
He gave a definition that goes way
beyond Bronsted and Lowry and is
free of all constraints of
composition. He said if you
recognize that what you are looking
for is something with a nonbonding
pair then let's talk about a base as
something that has the nonbonding
pair. That is to say,
in the past we said it was a proton
acceptor.
But why don't we look at the
nonbonding pair.
Remember how I gave you that
analogy with the traffic?
Don't look at the car, look at the
car vacancy. Instead,
don't look at the proton,
look at the nonbonding electrons.
What we had before is we said that
the Bronsted-Lowry base
had a nonbonding pair.
What Lewis says is don't talk about
this as a proton acceptor,
let's talk about this as an electron
pair donor. He is following the
vacancy instead of the car.
Anything that is an electron pair
donor he is going to call a base.
And then he is going to call what
is the mate to this?
It does not have to be a proton.
It could be anything that is a
capable of accepting electrons,
so I am going to call that a hollow
orbital. My acid is anything that
is an electron pair acceptor.
And now look at this.
This is the highest
conceptualization.
My neutralization reaction,
acid plus base gives solvent.
Electron pair nonbonding. Empty
orbital. What happens if I take an
electron pair nonbonding and mate it
with an empty orbital?
What do I form? A bond.
This is very, very high level.
It is gorgeous. It is absolutely
gorgeous.
And it is not restricted to aqueous
solutions. This is Darwin.
He is rising out of the water.
He can talk about gas reactions,
about solid state reactions. This
is free of all constraints.
This is electron pair plus empty
orbital gives bond.
All dative chemistry,
all dative bonds are captured here.
This is huge.
Let's take a look at an example
where that would come into play and
we will wrap into some environmental
stuff as well.
I mentioned earlier about burning
coal. In the United States,
about 50% of our electrical energy
is generated in coal fired power
plants, 17% natural gas,
3% petroleum. There is very little
that is non-carbon right now.
And industrial coal contains sulfur
at the ratio of about 1%.
It is an impurity in coal.
And one ton of coal will burn to
give you about 25 million British
thermal units or 2.
times ten to the tenth joules of
energy. Here is a nice figure to
remember. Three tons of coal gives
you one megawatt day.
A megawatt is a power unit.
You take power times time and you
have energy. If you generate one
megawatt for 24 hours that is an
energy unit. You need
three tons of coal.
And, just for comparison,
you would need one gram of uranium.
Think three tons coal, one gram
uranium. You make policy.
A ten megawatt plant burns about 30
tons of coal a day,
given that ratio, generating a third
of a ton of sulfur which makes
two-thirds of a ton of SO2 because
it goes up the stack and burns.
We can reduce sulfur dioxide
emissions. Why do we care?
Because sulfur dioxide eventually
becomes H2SO4. This is a
precursor to acid rain.
What we can do is trap sulfur
dioxide on lime,
CaO, to form calcium sulfite.
I am going to do that thanks to G.
. Lewis. Here is the reaction.
Here is sulfur dioxide.
It is sulfur with two oxygens.
This is a double bond and a single
bond, so this is resonant.
Each of these bonds is really about
one and a half order.
And calcium oxide, as you know,
is an ionic oxide. It is calcium
cation and oxide anion.
Oxide anion has nonbonding pairs to
beat the band.
How many are nonbonding pairs?
Four. What it can do is it can
sidle up next to the SO2,
if SO2 is made to pass over a bed of
lime. And here is what happens.
One of these electron pairs is
donated to the sulfur which then
breaks this double and forms three
bonds. Why does it
form three bonds?
Because three bonds is stabler than
two bonds. Thanks to this,
we have calcium oxide acting as a
Lewis base. Actually,
the O double minus is a Lewis base,
according to this definition. Base
is an electron pair donor.
SO2 is a Lewis acid. It better be.
You know SO2 leads to H2SO4. That
is acidic. If I have a new
definition that tells me that it is
basic, I don't like that.
This is consistent.
SO2 is a Lewis acid.
It accepts the electron pair.
And, instead of having a fugitive
SO2, it is now a solid calcium
sulfite, the volume is dramatically
reduced and now we can safely
dispose of the calcium sulfite and
take advantage of what we have
learned from G.
. Lewis. And on that happy note I
will say have a good weekend.
We will see you on Monday.